bonjour mon service ou bonjour où
vous êtes toujours dans la zone germanophone
se trouvent ou ailleurs les suivants
l'enregistrement est une traduction du
français une série de conférences
faire face à l'énergie et au changement climatique
emploie deux équipes dont nous avons toujours
entendre plus dans la vie quotidienne et l'eng
reliés les uns aux autres mais leurs
impact profond sur notre
la société n'est généralement pas assez bonne
être reconnu sans ou simple
réflexion pour être compris un homme
qui ces dernières années en france
de plus en plus pour une meilleure compréhension
du couplage énergie-changement climatique
s'est inquiété qu'il devrait certainement le
ingénieur de formation jacobi vous
s'intéresse depuis la fin des années 90
ans pour le problème du changement climatique
et développé les abeilles pour
méthode de facturation standardisée
bilan co2 france et autres
pays est depuis co-fondateur
une spécialisée dans les questions climatiques
société de conseil et en même temps
chef du groupe de réflexion du navire
Projet
Il est l'auteur de plusieurs livres et
enseigne aussi au français
universités dans le cadre de ces dernières
fonction derrière la suite
sermonner les éloquents mais comme toi
transmettre leurs connaissances spécialisées sur la base de
deux exemples et comparer et
aime en utiliser des plus simples mais pertinentes
ordre de grandeur souvent dans un peu
provocateur est-il connu comme
tête forte mais son précis
empreinte légèrement nette façon non
toujours bien accueillis néanmoins sont
ses idées comptent la façon de penser de
français ou au moins une partie de
pour vous comprendre quand il s'agit d'énergie
politique énergie industrie et environnement
va dans ces mots, nous vous souhaitons
instructif, sinon toujours
est agréable à entendre et attend avec impatience
Vos commentaires
si une question parce que nous avons demandé plus
saurez-vous qu'avec celui-ci
super jeu déjà vu
répondez ici à l'avance
signifie quand vous leur dites qu'elle est la
étudiant qui est là dans la deuxième rangée
assis avait un bleu comme le vert c
l'argent ou les centres noirs tout
le juste faire était de répondre
à côté les autres ont la bonne
Réponse
maintenant nous allons imaginer celui-là
question ouverte est posée qui est
qu'il elle arrête quelle est l'énergie elle
sachez qu'en france une énergie
les gens sont là pour pouvoir conduire quelque chose
c'est de l'énergie
normalement il devrait savoir par
qui est très ministre de l'énergie et comment
pose toi la question que je te pose
juste un exemple si vous réalisez que
la première réponse la plupart des
la population reçoit c'est c'est-à-dire
si vous êtes dans un certain nombre de
saisir particulier dans un cercle qui
se dit public et énergétique
parle il y a d'abord la paix
les gens pensent qu'il y a quelque chose
est que vous pouvez acheter un bien et
c'est en fait normal parce que c'est quelque chose
qui représentent également le premier type dans
le monde qu'est l'économiste parce qu'il est
Je suis heureux de l'acheter donc s'il
est cher ou bon marché et si nous l'obtenons
pourrait faire la même chose pour différents
obtenir moins d'argent
cela s'applique en particulier aux
messages parce que si vous voulez votre argent
savons et les avons suivis
Sais-tu que tu te bats avec le
commencer par le prix du carburant c'est
bien qu'ils ne soient peut-être pas les
raison principale, mais quand j'ai commencé à aider et
les prix du carburant mais les invités jamais
dit que nous ne voulons pas de carburant
consommer car cela génère trop de co2
ou nous ne voulons pas de carburant
consommer parce que c'est nous de russie
ou la Norvège à charge et que
ne voulons-nous pas qu'ils viennent de dire
c'est trop cher et j'ai compris ce que je
alors essayons-les pour une partie
du reste du cours est à expliquer
que vous manquez malheureusement le point parce que
voir la chose sous cet angle
considérez qu'il y a plusieurs raisons pour lesquelles
on passe à côté de l'essentiel c'est le premier
parce que vous le considérez strictement d'un point de vue économique
le coût pour le corps de l'énergie im
rapport avec les actes de revenus et
vous pouvez le faire de différentes manières
représentent l'un des types que j'ai
pour moi c'est demander c'est pour moi
pour voir quelle est l'économie
au total, le pétrole coûte du gaz chaque année
et le charbon qu'ils achètent pour
je l'ai fait fonctionner
Alors regardez l'ensemble de l'économie
produit de l'année et regardez-moi dans
référence au produit des interrupteurs à ce qu'il est
coûte tout le pétrole que nous utilisons
de l'année consomme dit le
invité que nous avons tout au long de l'année
mademoiselle j'ai été aidé comme chutes
total et tout le charbon que nous
au cours de l'année consommer sur le
marché à venir maintenant
les coûts représentent quelques pour cent de ce que
nous gagnons quelques pour cent de cela
ce que nous gagnons, je vous le montre
raccourcir un graphique sur ce que l'achat
des coûts d'approvisionnement en énergie et i
vous assurer que le paiement de
sfr orange vu moi aussi j'ai personne autour
dis bonjour je serai plus tard ou toi
sont où sont-ils à peu près pareils
le même prix que ça coûte
maintenant quelques pour cent de ce que vous
gagner et à partir du moment où
un article dans une économie avec
débattre quelques pour cent du débat
maquille toi maintenant en ce moment s'il te plait
être un réflexe normal de dire je le ferai
moi quelques pour cent actuellement à ce sujet
Prendre soin de
d'une manière typique comment
débats politiques en ce moment les suivants
Je suis intéressé par l'heure des élections
quelques pour cent actuellement peu et dans
agité parfois anni l'homme est plus loin
sur lequel je résous le problème des animaux et
te dire dans ton coin et comprendre
se soucie de la question, ce n'est pas
vraiment mon problème je vois
mauvais rapport avec les retraites
avec le la fête avec le
politique économique ou avec le nombre
l'imprimerie 100 il n'y a pas
contexte donc je vais le faire comme un
sujet considérer que du reste sur
est séparable et seulement quelques pour cent
prend mon temps c'est tellement
comme si je voulais te dire ton cerveau
deux pour cent de leur poids corporel
et donc peut être retiré que
n'est pas si mal parce qu'elle a fini
et seulement deux pour cent d'entre eux
l'efficacité globale
Il y a donc une couverture de graphique à secteurs
aucune information sur la façon dont un
les idéaux dépendent étroitement des autres et que
affecte non seulement l'énergie sont im
domaine de l'agriculture, par exemple celui-ci
zone des deux pour cent de la
btx français ça ne fait pas ça
beaucoup de si ces deux pour cent
faire ignorer quand
mais elle n'a rien à manger
alors ce sera difficile pour moi
98 % du PIB reste
produire
par conséquent on devrait avec le
les buteurs regardent faire attention aux
Les diagrammes ne montrent jamais à quel point le
parties différentes les unes des autres
lié à ce que je vais vous montrer
ce sera celui de 97 98 ou de 90
pour cent le PIB pas le
achats d'énergie dans
notre monde aujourd'hui complètement par le
les cinq pour cent restants dépendent dans
économie à berlin plus énergie
il doit être considéré comme un calculateur d'électricité
mais pas de compte il y en a d'autres
pensées que les garçons forment sens
venez architecte si nous par exemple
une bonne énergie est économisée
maintenant cela m'amène à mon deuxième
point que vous regardez cette vidéo
peut et avoir la guerre en attendant
faire une bonne affaire ou
écouter au lieu d'être 1000 ouvert à la
rappelez-vous que le monde dans les deux derniers
de plus en plus d'énergie au fil des siècles
Alors le monde a dévoré derrière
en conséquence, le résultat est approprié
un préservatif de plus en plus énergétique et
en aucun cas l'un des plus
économie d'énergie la bonne énergie la
à l'émergence de notre industrie
la société nourrie est exactement cela
énergie qui n'a pas été économisée
troisième problème est qu'il n'a pas d'importance de savoir
ce qu'est exactement l'énergie, l'essentiel est qu'elle soit
parce que ou pourcentage renouvelable nous devenons
trouver que le leur
en fait s'est passé différemment
une bonne approche en termes d'énergie pourrait
une problématique poétique est que
signifie que l'énergie est ce que vous avez en vous
demain il y a le 14 sentir ou
l'après-midi selon l'heure à laquelle vous vous levez
c'est la bonne façon de voir les choses
se sent en forme et plein d'énergie
l'homme la capacité d'être le destin dans le
à prendre en main si vous en avez beaucoup
l'énergie est en pleine forme
il y a peu de soucis avec ça
nous la capacité d'être le destin
contrôle et cela l'amène à la
point qui signifie avoir de l'énergie
pouvoir contrôler son environnement
est précis sur beaucoup d'énergie aussi
avoir les moyens d'avoir la capacité
pouvoir contrôler son environnement
pourquoi est-ce parce que l'énergie est devant
vous une facture de services publics ou un article
une discussion est physique
Taille
les connaissances transmises aux étudiants
c'est quand même assez marrant à cause de ça
en physique il y a complètement
des définitions claires des élites i
faire une suggestion pour moi est le
énergie ce que vous déclarez changer
Je peux écrire un système ferati
ne comprends pas que si nier que quoi
changer l'état d'un
systèmes calcule en d'autres termes par
plus notre monde change que
il y a plus d'énergie est un jeu plus
l'énergie entre en jeu plus
notre monde change si facilement
est
donc si j'ai aussi les changements dans le
reviens tous les jours voici quelques
exemples d'objets qui affectent l'environnement dans
tous les jours si
ceci dit le changement de température
soit pour se réchauffer soit pour se rafraîchir
et consommer ou donner ces objets
éventuellement retour d'énergie ce sont
suis mis à changer un
vitesse avec la voiture, il ne fera que
tout est question de vitesse
modifier le contenu de l'auteur qui
est-elle elle-même et toutes les valises
si tu pars en vacances maintenant un
changer de vitesse est un changement ou
un changement de vitesse pour changer
état d'un système ce sont des objets
ils devraient changer le formulaire
avait de la terre la terre est creusée
et à côté de la femme qui frappe met la comédie
ils avaient une boîte qui est de l'étain
avoué et ils ont une porte de voiture
transformer ces machines consomment
énergie vous avez de l'énergie dans le jeu
le changement d'un produit chimique
composition
d'ailleurs, le premier produit chimique
composition en constante évolution
si ton nom entoure aussi l'énergie
délivrer s'appelle la digestion de
la nourriture qu'ils mangent ils ont des énergies
correspondent si vous avez des champs magnétiques
les courants électriques l'établissent ainsi
peut soit être installé dans un rotor
être fourni ou dans une machine
sera
ils en ont joué un quand ils
millions dans un arrangement carinthien
Et tu sais que le soleil est ton tout
y passer du temps
un grand thermonucléaire permanent
le côté passera des noyaux d'hydrogène
composer environnement connaître
obtenez vous avez le pouvoir dans le jeu à
l'interaction entre la matière et
rayonnement une interaction entre
la matière et le rayonnement sur lesquels vous
probablement particulièrement intéressé
sont leurs smartphones
en général, l'utilisation de
l'énergie donc rien d'autre que ça
transformer le monde qui nous entoure et
à l'inverse, la transformation du monde qui nous entoure
autour signifie inévitablement que l'énergie
entre en jeu
une première petite remarque maintenant que
Je leur ai dit qu'une fois dans
en france nous avons un ministère pour
la transition énergétique et pas seulement l'énergie
ministère pour lequel nous avons un honneur
la transition énergétique désormais le ministère de
la transition énergétique est probablement celle
le plus ancien ministère de l'humanité
communauté les gens derrière côté
500 000 ans avec la transition énergétique
est employé il y a 500 000 ans
la seule énergie était celle du peuple
pourrait utiliser son corps aurait et
puis nous avons commencé le temps libre
alors investis le premier
ont l'énergie extracorporelle des articles
nous avons commencé toutes les énergies renouvelables
et d'ailleurs aussi quelques fossiles
domestiquer les carburants
par exemple, peut-être déjà
mille ans que tant de gens lisent huileux
charbon qu'à cette époque en petites quantités et
en fait c'était industriel
révolution
la domestication des énergies fossiles
on peut revenir à ça et c'est comme ça
la transition énergétique une der permanente
état d'humanité à chaque fois
nous trouvons un moyen un nouveau
pour utiliser la source d'énergie nous le faisons quoi
elle vise le quartier moderne
tu verras que c'est extrêmement fort
caractérisée et c'est là le problème
est que nous l'ordre de grandeur de ce
processus en très très peu de temps
radicalement changé au fil du temps
l'énergie est tellement va je vous l'ai dit
une taille physique à partir de ce moment
dans lequel j'ai dit que l'énergie a
la taille physique est-ce que cela signifie que
il y a toutes les chances qu'il y ait cette énergie de
les lois ne statueront pas contre
peut changer c'est la bonne chose
les lois de la physique
donc vous pouvez comprendre que quoi
la comparaison max elle-même mais si vous
une fois que vous les comprenez, vous pouvez
ne change plus alors je peux dire
ici ce serait pour le pouvoir d'achat de
consommateur sympa si on utilise le maxwell
les équations changeraient une de moins
eh bien, en ce qui concerne l'énergie, il y a
certaines lois qui s'appliquent également à nous
et je ne peux pas changer les heures où nous allons
ainsi dit c'est l'énergie qui
transformation de la qualité environnementale
la première loi du capital relative à celle
sur l'énergie très facile à retenir
C'est le premier principe de
thermodynamique ou énergie
statut de conservation
maintenant celui appliqué à l'homme
la loi de conservation de l'énergie a un effet très
conséquence simple à savoir que le
les gens ne peuvent rien faire d'autre que ça
l'environnement à l'énergie déjà disponible
y échapper et bien que son avantage
c'est tout ce que tu vas consommer
les gens dans le sens où les gens
la situation serait de l'énergie à l'intérieur
à comparaître et avec le
communiquer avec le monde extérieur
serait le premier principe de la thermodynamique
blesser je peux le faire dans le bon sens
mais harry potter fait dans le monde réel
est-ce qu'il en serait ainsi nous avons besoin de chaque énergie
le danger qu'il faut trouver dans l'environnement
tout prélèvement d'énergie qui est dans le
environnement est le jargon de
les scientifiques de l'énergie comme principaux
appelée énergie
donc si vous êtes quelque part dans le
Statistiques incluses puis voir
désigne l'énergie dans l'environnement
faire semblant qu'il y en a un autre
a très bien compris le secteur de l'énergie
est commun
l'énergie finale est l'énergie que le compteur
de la consommation d'énergie pour est mesurée
Alors, qui est l'utilisateur final?
si vous êtes à la maison et un gaz ou
avoir de l'électricité ou si vous en avez une
sont plus industriels et dix
ont parce qu'ils crient du gaz dans un verre
alors utilisez dès que
consommateur final, qu'il soit privé ou
l'énergie industrielle vous l'achète
permet à une machine de fonctionner
on parle d'énergie dans le
environnement avant à la valeur énergétique que
principalement appelé énergie et entre les deux
est évidemment l'énergie de swing
le style est vu à travers, tout comme le
premier homme célibataire à utiliser
la nourriture blanche et la chaleur du soleil
historiquement le seul
convertisseur d'énergie que les humains
disponible elle-même veut
pour consommer de l'énergie il en faut une
forêt d'énergie était vous avez de l'énergie dans
mettre quelque chose à l'intérieur pour les fermer
transformer la seule transition énergétique quand
donc les gens ont eux-mêmes
donc les gens mangent ils se chauffent dedans
le soleil se lève et sort de ces énergies
ils viennent en fait
chaleur ou peu travailleur im
tout au long de l'histoire, nous avons
amorcé une autre transition énergétique
à utiliser en complément de l'utilisation du bois
nous avons commencé à une houle possible
vu des coins renouvelables à cette époque
appartenait aussi à d'autres vies de
organistes sur les énergies renouvelables
parce qu'ils changent complètement ce qui vous arrive
les peuples de mon ils mangent des poursuites
skat et générer en conséquence un
Nous avons beaucoup d'énergie, de vent et d'eau
ainsi que d'éventuelles dîmes au bar
europe avec de l'eau et plus tard du vinyle
couverts, il est important de souligner que
les énergies renouvelables ne sont pas l'avenir
mais pas passé donc pas
dans le sens où tu n'es pas d'accord avec ça
sont prometteurs mais qu'ils
d'il y a un siècle et tel
appartenait à la vie de tous les jours et je sais très bien
tout comme un monde d'explications à 100%
on dirait que j'en ai au moins un
indice le contrat mondial 100 oui
ce monde fonctionnera à 100%
d'autres étaient et sont d'accord avec ça
un milliard vivait dans ce monde
les gens dont l'espérance de vie a été trompée
entre 30 et 40 ans et deux
le tiers de la population travaillait également
Eh bien, ce monde peut réellement suivre
Fonctionnement 100 % renouvelable
il n'y a pas de problème cette expérience
nous l'avons déjà fait bien sûr
le débat d'aujourd'hui est que nous pouvons
notre civilisation actuelle avec tous les
des gens des machines qui traitent avec nous
atteindre 100% d'énergie dessus
nous reviendrons et vous encore
puis il y a deux siècles
des ingénieurs brillants et des brillants
le physicien a dit ici d'autres savent
les mots énergétiques utilisent la transition énergétique
qui ne se répètent pas dans ce cas
machines le jugement et nous le ferons
l'approvisionnement en énergie l'énergie son utilisation
nous à grande échelle jusqu'à maintenant
ne domine pas petit fossile
combustibles
alors en voici une courte
résumé de l'historique énergétique
de l'humanité avant tout
energiewende même alors c'était d'autres
créatures il y avait dépliant
après cela nous sommes venus de nouvelles énergies
y compris les machines métalliques et
le carburant
donc ce que je vous dis c'était quelque chose
essentiel que nous consommons réellement
pas d'énergie en dehors de ce que nous
manger si vous promettez de lg
J'ai qu'une mauvaise désignation parce que
si je ne me trompe pas je pense que oui
pas qu'ils aient jamais bu de l'huile
sinon n'hésitez pas à me contacter
Je ne pense pas qu'ils signalent non plus
avoir des scènes autres que contre les flatulences
est utilisé et je crois aussi
pas qu'ils soient venus avec une dent
donc nous n'avons pas besoin d'énergie avec nous
notre propre corps et quand nous
Dire que nous consommons de l'énergie est
c'est effectivement un abus de langage
mais c'est un abus de langage
une illusion d'optique a fait ressortir
la consommation d'énergie est extrêmement forte
signifie en effet une machine aussi
but assoiffé donc le prési électoral
dénomination de la consommation d'énergie pour vous
même de temps en temps dans celui-ci
enseigner parce que j'utilise cette abréviation de et
à nouveau je veux utiliser le commutateur
supprimer et remplacer par les mots
utilisation de machines
et partout où vous voyez que nous avons toujours
ils utilisent plus d'énergie pour filer
sortir et remplacer par nous mettons toujours
plus une machine qui est importante aussi
comprendre et est en effet le
quantité croissante d'énergie que nous
utiliser rien d'autre que le genre et
sage comme nous la nouvelle mécanique
exosquelette qui sera à notre profit
ont créé augmenter proportionnellement
c'est l'énergie et ce monde de
machines c'est le monde dans lequel vous
donner si je ne me trompe pas
vous sur la base des normes légales et
du temps habillé dans cette chambre
donc quand ils sont habillés ils ont
parfois une utilisation de vêtement
un vêtement qui a peur de s'enfiler aussi
dure même lorsqu'il est extrêmement maladroit
sont exactement quelques secondes maintenant dans
quelques secondes vous avez des milliers de
machines mobilisées à votre profit
sans s'en rendre compte, d'abord, ils ont tous
ces machines agricoles aussi
il mobilise son bénéfice
textile dit naturel
avoir pourquoi était le lin et ainsi de suite
ils ont tous de l'agriculture
machines à leur profit critique le
coton semis récolte et enfin
tu sauras si tu en as un
utilisez donc des fibres textiles synthétiques
tout ce que le polyester vient d'apprendre et des trucs comme ça
alors tout est fait d'huile
fabriqué
donc si vous avez des sous-vêtements ou un t
mettre un maillot avec des phases synthétiques
alors vous avez un morceau de plate-forme pétrolière
plus un morceau de vapocraqueur plus
s'ils sont autre chose que
injuste et le tissu a conduit d'où
donc le nid d'abeille devait être fait
sera pour qui était donc le produit chimique
industrie utilisée à l'avance
viennent aussi les machines à l'avance
les fibres ont revécu
veux mécanique
l'autorité a dû être transportée pour cela
sera parce qu'évidemment le
citoyens pas là où ils sont appropriés
a également été tissé teint et ainsi de suite
ils ont aussi bien que d'autres machines
camions trains avions à un
étapes intermédiaires de la chaîne impliquées
sont utilisés pour le traitement chimique
où les climatiseurs ont construit cet hommage
centrales électriques nécessaires dans l'ensemble
pour soutenir le processus en bref
derrière une chose complètement inoffensive comme
se déguiser en pièces astucieuses
en fait une armée de machines après
qu'ils ont attiré et fui
faut aller les nettoyer d'habitude
Cela prend trois minutes si vous suivez les conseils
suivre le médecin et une minute
si vous regardez de côté ici, vous les avez aussi
un nombre important de machines
utilisé ici uniquement à cette fin
voir réellement un produit chimique
usine dans le nord de la france les protozoaires
appelé obtenir des fabricants d'outils dans
arrêter le dentifrice, c'est comme vous le savez
causé est trop calcaire
nous avons donc besoin pour
sucre dentifrice au bon goût
confère mais ne cause pas de carie dentaire
est l'un des nombreux
molécules qui viennent d'un fou suis
star eva briegel était là pour être
quotidiennement à partir de tonnes pour la plupart des centaines de
molécules ou dans le pot
réseau et sur site comptent quelques milliers
personnes en trois équipes qui l'exploitent
est l'un des plus grands de la chimie
froissé déplié puis ils ont le
tour de dentifrice non en métal
mais le plastique c'est le pouvoir
qui à son tour signifie plate-forme pétrolière
crack de vapeur de raffinerie et ainsi de suite
et le tube n'apparaît pas à travers le
effet du Saint-Esprit sur elle
a-t-il besoin d'un ancien étudiant en vous ici
voir et se brosser les dents avant
un miroir qui aussi en quelque sorte
il fallait les fabriquer
Ainsi, une entreprise qui est actuellement et à son tour
camions pour le transport chargement à vendre
et ainsi de suite
ensuite tu te brosseras les dents avec du matériel
l'eau grâce à une station d'épuration comme
Donc encore une fois une armée de
des machines pour le quotidien inoffensif
ont travaillé et peuvent se brosser les dents
moi à l'objet le plus important de ta vie
votre smartphone redevient le même
historique lorsque vous appelez quelqu'un
travail du soir une armée de machines
pour le
le plastique a fait l'eau
Je suis pour les antennes
ont produit 40 mètres à eux seuls
coincé dans votre smartphone
une concentration très faible cependant
au moins plusieurs dizaines d'autres
signifie que des activités
machines minières et ainsi de suite téléphones mobiles
nécessite également un travail
réseau de communication du tout
pour pouvoir communiquer les uns avec les autres ici
est, par exemple, un dispositif pour
passage de câbles autour du réseau
Un appel téléphonique est nécessaire pour venir
Donc des milliers de machines pour tout le monde
étapes intermédiaires de la construction et de son exploitation
de l'appareil ont été utilisés donc je
disons que ça marche encore aujourd'hui dans lequel nous vivons
un monde de machines et tout ça
les machines consomment invariablement
l'énergie chacun un objectif et devient ainsi le
raisonnement que je t'ai donné plus tôt
ont montré légèrement inversé il y a
pas seulement trois pour cent du pib il meurent
tu perds quand tu fermes le monde
la demande gouverne voit c'est joli
facile à comprendre ils n'en ont pas
transports de travail que vous avez
pas de banques pas d'approvisionnement en eau
les hôpitaux et juste là
moyens de transport parce qu'ils n'en ont pas
avoir un gel en manque d'énergie
et s'entre-tuer dans
en gros c'est ce qui se passe quand on
le monde immédiatement l'énergie demain matin
échapper à tout le monde moderne se bloque
Donc ça dépend et si c'est un pourcentage ou
100 pour cent coûte ce que vous méritez
pas vraiment le point je le pense
c'est un sujet mais c'est loin d'être le cas
pas le seul sujet